what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in light of the
crazy twists and turns that have rocked
a story of attack on Titan in the last
few chapters of the manga I decided to
make a video in which I speculate about
what in the world
Eren is going to do next and how the
attack on Titan story will ultimately
end because this video is speculative
and features multiple possible scenarios
for what will happen next I invite all
of you guys to share your own thoughts
down in the comments below what do you
think Aaron is going to do next and how
do you think attack on Titan is going to
end let's get a good discussion going
down in the comments I know that for me
personally talking about attack on Titan
with other people helps me deal with all
the craziness that was thrown our way in
these last few chapters if you enjoy the
attack on Titan content on this channel
and you'd like to see more please leave
a like to let me know and if you happen
to be new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications the
way that YouTube works if you don't make
sure to hit the notification bell and
click the option to turn on all
notifications you will most likely miss
a lot of our videos you could also
follow me on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest attack
on titan news and updates and finally if
it wasn't obvious already this video
will contain manga spoilers because we
are dealing with the latest developments
in the manga so please proceed with
caution you have been warned all right
so the big question is this now that
aaron has seemingly formed an alliance
with Aamir Fritz returned to the
physical world and initiated the
rumbling what in the world is he
planning to do next
we know that above all other things
Aaron wants freedom and he told Amir
that he wants to destroy this world at
least as it is in its current form we
can assume that Amir also wants freedom
after spending thousands of years as a
slave of the Royal Fritz family after
all
Aaron believes that Amir reached out to
him in the first place to you 2,000
years from now because she wanted him to
help her finally be free so ok Aaron
wants freedom and he thinks that this
world in its current state is
fundamentally on Joss
that's all well and good but the
question is how exactly does Aaron plan
to achieve his goal of attaining freedom
and changing this corrupt and cruel
world the question isn't what Aaron
wants to do but how he plans to do it
feel free to comment your thoughts on
what you think Aaron will do right now
and then after you finish watching the
video feel free to comment again and
tell me if anything in the video changed
or further developed your ideas the
first possibility that I want to explore
is the most simple one
Aaron plans to use the rumbling to
destroy the entire unjust world and
start anew that is why he initiated the
rumbling in the first place and that is
what he will use both the wall Titans
and Aamir's power to accomplish sure a
ton of people are going to die but Aaron
might think that this is the only way to
achieve a better world a lot of people
may have to die now but at least this
will lead to a better future instead of
hundreds and thousands of years of more
war suffering and injustice I'm not
saying that I support this obviously but
it just might be what he is thinking at
the moment this scenario would be in
line with the concept of Ragnarok which
is something I mentioned in previous
videos
in short attack on Titan is full of
direct references to Norse mythology and
in Norse mythology Ragnarok is a
prophecy about the end of the world the
apocalypse according to this prophecy
there will be a great war many will die
including the gods there will be great
natural disasters and calamities and
then in the end two people a man and a
woman will be the only survivors these
two people will then repopulate the
earth and create a new and better world
we know that the final panel of the
attack on Titan manga is going to
feature an adult holding a child with
the text reading you are free so perhaps
this was a hint that a Ragnarok esque
event will occur and only a few people
will survive but those few people will
then truly be free this would be a
pretty messed up ending because it would
turn the protagonist of the story eren
yeager into a ruthless mass murderer but
that would also make it a unique and
memorable ending to say the least I
don't think that this ending is outside
of the realm of possibility but there
are other possibilities as
well in another scenario Aaron doesn't
use the rumbling to destroy the entire
world instead he uses the rumbling to
destroy only a certain portion of the
world for example he decides to destroy
Marlay as a warning for the rest of the
world to stay away from parodies or he
destroys all the army's planning to
attack parodies again as a warning
stay away or we will kill you all just
like we killed your soldiers however the
problem with this scenario is that one
of the most important messages of the
attack on titan story is that you cannot
stop the future you cannot stop progress
and postpone the inevitable at least not
forever king carl frits attempted to
isolate himself from the world and to
stop all technological progress on the
island of parodies but that was always
doomed to failure
so why would Eren succeed where Carl
Fritz failed sure if Aaron destroys a
massive army or even levels all of
Marlay the rest of the world will be
scared and they will stay away for a
time but as modern technology continues
to advance and one day those other
countries develop weapons of mass
destruction like nukes
you better believe that they will attack
the LD ends again the problem with
instilling fear into someone is that
eventually they will realize that the
only way to stop being afraid of you is
to destroy you and that is what the rest
of the world will eventually do to the
audience if Aaron uses fear as his only
tactic for achieving freedom another
option for what Aaron might do next is
the time loop theory which I covered in
an entire video that you can watch if
you click the link in the description to
be brief the idea here is that because
the attack Titan has the ability to
access future memories and even
influence the past perhaps together with
the Emir's power Aaron would be able to
turn back time
perhaps the reason why his story alok so
much like a mere fritz is because the
child that historia is carrying is none
other than amir fritz herself once the
baby is born aaron will attempt to turn
back time in order to change the past
and stop all the suffering that took
place over the past 2,000 years this
type of ending would be a mined funk for
sure and yes I said funk because it's
YouTube in 2019 but I don't think that
this is very likely and I mentioned this
in my video on the time
theory as well this type of ending would
definitely have us talking about it for
years to come but it just wouldn't be
satisfying at all in my opinion and it
wouldn't allow the story to progress in
the way that it has been so far clearly
there are important messages in attack
on Titan about the need to be free to
accept the future to accept progress and
to keep moving forward this might
actually be the whole point of attack on
Titan and this is why an ending that
traps the world of attack on Titan
inside a time loop does not make sense
to me from a narrative perspective
although to be fair you never know with
our boy Hajime isayama to say that he
has managed to surprise us in these past
few chapters would be a massive
understatement we also have the lelouch
from Code Geass scenario this is the
idea that Eren might make himself out to
be a villain the worst evil in the world
that everyone can agree must be stopped
including the LD ends the Marlins and
every other nation in existence in this
scenario Aaron's immense power and
villainy forces every nation to work
together in order to defeat him and in
the process of defeating Eren all the
nations including the Marlins and the LD
ins realize that they share a common
goal and that they are all just human
beings who can work together and live in
peace
Eren eventually allows himself to be
defeated he makes the ultimate sacrifice
in order for a new world to emerge a
world where the different nations live
together in peace after defeating their
common enemy Eren Yeager this is a
plausible scenario and we have talked
about it many times here on the channel
however I do see some major problems
with this scenario in the context of the
attack on Titan world in particular the
other nations of the world have a deep
distrust of LD ends and a deep fear of
them because of their ability to turn
into Titans even if all the nations work
together to defeat Eren as soon as the
threat is gone the other nations will
still be afraid of the LD ends and they
will still likely try to eliminate them
so that they can never pose a threat to
humanity in the future this could
potentially be resolved if Eren uses the
power of Amir Fritz to take away the
ability of the audience to turn into
Titans before he is defeated but even
then you are relying on the goodwill of
the other nations including the marlins
for the survival of the LDN people are
we sure that the other nations will
actually believe that
the audience can no longer turn into
Titans what if the other nations think
that the aliens are playing a trick on
them and that they can still turn into
Titans anyway knowing how human nature
works it is very likely that the other
nations will still turn against the
audience just in case the titan powers
are still in their blood or just in case
these powers somehow return at some
point in the future don't forget that
much of the world views LD ins as the
spawn of the devil and this type of vile
propaganda is deeply ingrained into the
psyche of the marlins
and other nations even though this
propaganda is indeed false there is no
devil to speak of it would be naive for
Aaron to assume that sacrificing himself
to get the LD ins and other nations to
work together would automatically lead
to world peace I mean if we just look at
our own world even though most of the
world had a common enemy in the Axis
powers during World War two as soon as
World War two ended the Allies turned on
each other and the Cold War began
another scenario is that Aaron will just
go full villain although this one is
highly unlikely
in this scenario Aaron develops a god
complex like Light Yagami from Death
Note and Aaron uses Amir's powers and
the rumbling to rule the world with an
iron fist he may even decide to consume
all nine Titan powers to make himself as
powerful as possible and maybe even
defeat the curse since we now know that
a mere fritz did not die because of an
illness or curse it is possible that
someone who possesses all nine Titan
powers at once is immune from the
dreaded curse of aamir but this would
require Aaron to change completely as a
character instead of freedom he would be
embracing tyranny and he would
potentially be required to kill his own
friends like Armin in order to consume
all nine Titan powers this scenario is
fun to think about in terms of seeing a
protagonist turning into a complete
deranged villain but I personally don't
buy it at all although after that game
of Thrones final season nothing would
shock me at this point probably the most
realistic scenario for what Aaron will
do next and how the attack on Titan
story will end is that the world of
attack on Titan will end up looking a
lot like our own world in this scenario
Aaron uses the rumbling to destroy all
the armies who are trying to threaten
parodies but then instead of
using fear and the threat of further
destruction to keep the other nations in
line he actually decides to embrace
technological progress a process that
has already started on the island of
parodies Aaron uses the threat of the
Titans as a way to keep the other
nations at bay while the people in
parodies catch up to everyone else in
terms of modern technology and weaponry
that way even though modern technology
will one day completely surpassed the
power of the Titans the LD ins will
still be able to defend themselves
because they will also possess the most
advanced weapons eventually Aaron could
even use Amir's power to take away the
ability of aliens to transform into
Titans in the first place and then the
LD ins would be just like every other
nation in the world
no Titan curse no children of the devil
just good old-fashioned firepower this
scenario requires Aaron to engage not
only in destruction but also in
statecraft Aaron would have to become
more than just a soldier he would have
to become a statesman a ruler who is
working to build a modern and prosperous
nation he would have to build
partnerships and alliances with other
nations like his uru he would have to
grow the economy promote trade and so on
eventually once the attack on Titan
world develops the equivalent of nuclear
weapons the audience could protect
themselves through the principle of
mutually assured destruction this is the
concept that if two countries both
possess incredible weapons of mass
destruction like nuclear weapons going
to war with each other would lead to the
destruction of both countries
if either country attacks the other both
will be destroyed because both have
enough weapons to destroy the other in
such a war there would be no winner and
for this reason there is no incentive to
ever go to war in the first place
if the story of attack on titan decides
to go in a practical real politic
direction then this would be the most
likely scenario for the ending this type
of ending isn't the most dramatic or
explosive and being dramatic and
explosive is definitely what attack on
titan does best but if he decides to
make the ending one in which not
everyone has to die and one in which the
audience have a future Hajime isayama
may opt for this realpolitik ending that
focuses on statesmanship and realist
international relations personally I am
undecided on which type of ending
isayama will ultimately
shoes my personal opinion is that he
will probably go either with the
Ragnarok ending or with the
statesmanship ending but I would be a
fool if I said that I can predict what a
syama will do
he has surprised all of us so many times
in the past so at the end of the day we
just have to sit back and enjoy the ride
let me know what you guys think do you
like any of the scenarios that I
discussed or do you have a totally
different idea
hit me up down in the comments if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more attack on titan content here on the
channel please leave a like to let me
know and if you happen to be new to
anime uproar don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications you could also
follow me on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar for all the latest attack
on titan news and updates i want to give
a big thank you to all of our anime out
pro patrons who make videos like this
one possible special thank you to all of
our pro hero to your patrons including
the one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson King's eldest son he'll
cruise stealers poet Pablo
atropos Wraith very dolla beat karate
GaN Anatoly Cassatt's ki
TJ Nathaniel and alpha do and I can't
forget the ones that rise above all
other clans a massive thank you to all
of our the one tier patrons including in
grata alone Adam Maddie Mac makoto-kun
and yuh boys Seth if you enjoy our
videos and you think that they add some
value to your life consider supporting
us on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these amazing people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see us bass
cowboys
[Music]